(pensive music)
- [Narrator] These are some of the scenes
in the Reykjanes Peninsula of Iceland
after a volcanic eruption began expelling
lava in the region.
- This style of eruption
differs somewhat from the kind
of popular culture explosions
that you might see.
(explosions blasting)
(air whooshing)
- [Narrator] Here's why this
eruption looks so different
and what threats it poses.
Iceland is home to more than 130 volcanoes
across more than 30 volcanic systems,
and right now, lava is erupting
out of the Svartsengi volcanic system
located in the Reykjanes
Peninsula of southwest Iceland.
- In a traditional volcano,
the volcanic material funnels
through a central vent,
typically, like in those volcanoes
that you ideate in Hollywood
where there is a mountain,
and a conical peak, and the summit,
and everything, like,
flows out of the summit,
whether that's an ash plume
that explodes explosively into the sky,
or whether the lava comes
up and out of the center
and, like, leaks down
the side of the mountain.
Here, it's not like that.
- [Narrator] Instead, in
this type of eruption,
known as a fissure eruption,
lava basically oozes
from cracks in the ground,
and the type of lava typically
involved in these two kinds
of eruptions also looks different.
An explosive eruption is often
due to viscous, sticky magma
that doesn't flow easily,
while a fissure eruption pushes
out fluid and runny magma that
spreads across the landscape.
- The big danger with these is
that these lava flows can
spread out quite a long way,
and obviously, as we're
seeing in Iceland right now,
that poses a threat to
both the infrastructure
in the region and people's lives.
- [Narrator] The eruption
from the Svartsengi volcanic
system occurred near Grindavik,
an Icelandic fishing town.
The surrounding area is
home to a major airport,
one of the country's most
popular tourist attractions,
the Blue Lagoon, and a power
plant that provides hot water
for the majority of the peninsula.
Eruptions in this part of
Iceland have been increasing
steadily in recent years after
a very long dormant period.
- This is just an area
of Iceland that goes
through these periodic eras of
on-and-off eruption activity
and then quiescence, so, like,
around a millennia or so,
the peninsula is quiet.
You don't see volcanic
activity, and then it starts up.
(lava roaring)
And then that era of volcanic
activity lasts for centuries.
- [Narrator] Iceland sits
on top of the Eurasian
and North American tectonic
plates, making it a hotbed
of seismic and volcanic activity.
When the tectonic plates
slip past one another,
earthquakes occur, and as
the plates spread apart,
magma can leak up to the surface,
generating volcanic eruptions.
- The focus of sort of monitoring efforts
of volcanic systems is around
trying to identify as early
as possible any precursory
signals that sort of come
before the onset of an eruption.
And in instances like what
we're seeing in Iceland,
these eruptions are typically
heralded by these sort
of really high levels of seismic activity
to try and really tell us where
there might be an eruption
and sort of where ongoing
intrusions are going.
- [Narrator] It remains to
be seen how the lava erupting
from the Svartsengi volcanic
system will impact residents
in the surrounding area.
But the risk of volcanic
activity also comes
with benefits for the Icelandic community.
- Every expert from Iceland
who I spoke with was very proud
of the fact that the
country uses their volcanoes
in a constructive way.
They harness geothermal energy from them
to generate electricity,
and heat their water,
and heat their homes, and
they don't need to buy oil
to do those things
because they're exploiting
their volcanoes, basically.
But of course, the trade off there is,
in order to exploit them best,
you have to be close to them,
and if you're close to them, eventually,
an eruption will threaten
homes, threaten towns
and cities, and with risks come benefits.
(pensive music)